Paul has just shown me since I talked
about
quotes on Monday he he showed me a
book that he was reading that that just
happened to be a nice quote for uh for
our course and so this is this is by Kem
kamu the plague what
okay
no no this is translated in English but
it's a he's it's a story about this
writer who's um
who's visiting his doctor he says what I
really want doctors this on the day when
the manuscript reaches the publisher I
want him to stand up after he's read it
through of course in the sake of the
staff gentleman hats off
um
this is something like what I wanted
when I was writing a Scientific American
article when I when I okay then he says
it
um
he was uh almost excruciating pains to
bring it to Perfection evenings whole
week spent on one word just think
sometimes on a mere conjunction
I'd like you to understand I grant you
it's easy enough to choose between but
and and it's a bit more difficult to
decide between and and them but
definitely the hardest thing may be to
know whether one should put an N or
leave it out
and uh I think that'll come up in
discussion today too probably somewhere
in here anyway
um
opening phrase is giving me no end of
trouble
um
and here's the and he starts out with
the beginning sentence which is terrible
um it's almost as bad as a dark and
stormy night you know but anyway uh
um
he was all right well anyway what do you
think of it doctor in all this and so um
it's only a rough draft oh well it's it
looks like something I'd like to read
the rest of them
so I guess I should yeah you know this
quarter I'm writing in this book
concrete math and uh
and I could probably describe to you
some of the joys and Sorrows associated
with this because it's some sort of I'm
sort of you know filled with it all
um and I had this great um
inspiration during the summer I mean I
went to see Walt Disney I went to see
Snow White and Seven Dwarfs and I came
out of that movie and I said boy that's
really an incredible work of art who
could have conceived the doing that what
uh in 1937 who could have conceived of
doing such a project and carrying it
through and getting it getting it out
and everything and I said boy you know I
would love to I would want to create a
work of art like this and in my this
book concrete math is going to have to
be just just a gem
um
uh with one condition however and that
is that I want to finish it in three
months
um I mean I want to I want to write the
greatest possible work of art except
that I that I only got three months
because I really have many other things
to do so all right so I I'm not able to
spend three months on a conjunction you
know in this in this book
um but I did I was inspired anyway I
tried to do my best but on the other
hand I know I have to crank out about
four pages a day on the average and I
mean that's average that's every day
including Saturdays and Sundays and so
uh and so this meant um
um
not slacking off and and uh and and
keeping to a fairly fairly rigid
schedule still I'm here it is uh
November already and I'm still
reasonably happy
um
and I took time out last night to see a
fast Fender movie I wondered what that
was a kind of a crazy film but uh it was
a good break in other words uh uh I
haven't been working uh 24 hours a day
on this book although I have to really
you know concentrate out now yesterday I
finished breakfast and I said well maybe
I'll take a nap and uh you know I knew
that I should really I should really
write some more about asymptotics and uh
I wasn't really enthused about it well
then I decided to get warmed up I would
go I would go proofread some of the
stuff that already been written in the
chapter and and uh and actually it's a
chapter it started out rather well I
thought so I was glad you know when I
looked at it and so that that encouraged
me to to go on and then I had another
idea how to fix something and so and
once I got get over the threshold and
get started on it then I get interested
in the subject and you know and uh and
enjoy the and enjoy the writing and
especially afterwards after a tough
problem has been solved
um that's there's actually pleasure
there
um but on Sunday I was just I was so mad
I was probably going to go out of my
mind I just couldn't find a way to to
make this exam I mean I I had a perfect
derivation of everything except I needed
one result that that needed the theory
of uh of complex variables or or Fourier
series or something that wasn't in the
book and uh and I didn't wanna you know
I like the book to be self-contained and
I and I struggled over and over again I
tried this to find
to find proofs of this of this of this
result uh probably impossible so I
finally had to flush it from my mind and
get over there get over that hand but uh
but I it did affect me I mean I was I
was a not a very uh lovable person on
Sunday afternoon and finally I I uh I
wrote a letter to Ron Graham was
co-author and said Ron see if you can
find it and otherwise I'll just quote it
as something you know that it can be
proved that or you know it's something
that beyond the scope of the book but
also happens to be true
um it would be nice to have the whole
book self-contained but it might be
impossible maybe this was a result Euler
didn't know and I don't go any any past
the mathematics whatever I know anyway
this is uh but I try to give you some of
the feeling that I have about as I'm
writing the book of
um sometimes
awake in the morning with an with an
idea that says that you know I just say
oh yeah this is going to be perfect for
the thing and other days I say well
um I I've got to do this book today or
else and so I have so I do it and I get
started as a duty
um
uh when you and uh generally once I get
started
um that's the hard part
now uh you've got one more week right to
do your speaking of cranking out pages
per day and so on next Wednesday is
is the day we'd like you to turn in the
as much as you have of the term paper
and the more the better because I have
two professional
um professionals who will actually be
reading it and making feedback on it one
is uh Mary Claire and you know one is
Rosalie stemmer who will be who will be
lecturing also on what she sees in your
in your drafts and so
um and so I take advantage of this of
this golden opportunity to get um
to get a special expertise for for
feedback
and
the rest of today I want to talk about
some one of my battles with professional
feedback
um the um
the outcome the uh
I
I'm certainly the first to admit that I
don't know everything about writing but
but I I it's also reassuring I I suppose
to know that the people who Who Do It
full time for a living
um don't know everything either uh Paul
no you just raised your hand no because
he did hey
okay and so um so let me let me give you
the try to give you the experience so
here's a here's the
beginning of the correspondence is it's
um 1975.
um uh from the editor of Scientific
American a man who who does it
accomplishes an awful lot and so he's
say he's inviting me uh to write an
article and he says uh he'd like it to
be six thousand words long
if you're inclined to proceed we'd like
to have it by October one on a customary
payment for the article is 500.
uh what does that come to per word is
that 12 cents a word
that's right
no
I wish for you divide by but how do you
do this okay five hundred dollars
now the
divided by 6 000 words so it's the other
way around isn't it so it's what
eight point three cents a word okay so
you know each and constantly
8.3 cents in the bank well actually I
should make that um after the article
was published they they put it in their
reprint series which they give
especially to high school students and
they and uh and they and they they give
they give royalties to the authors of
this reference series I get a half a
penny for every reap into this article I
take
that they sell and uh amazingly enough
uh uh I've been getting five or ten
dollars a year for the last 10 years
from from this which means you know ten
dollars that's two thousand reprints or
something like that so they're using so
they're using this you know it's a big
money owner
um
I also got a
a royalty from the Russians of uh one
Copic for every uh copy of the art of
computer programming that that they
published
but that was 200 000 copies and so uh uh
that amount it's a 2 000 rubles which is
like you didn't know how to spend but I
mean it was nice to have nice to have
nice that that they would give me one
kopeck for us now
um
so you see there's money associated with
writing and Jeff Bowman says he's going
to talk a little bit more about that
next week uh in part of his talk but he
wants to talk mostly most of the time
about the the uh something about Rising
above minutia minutiae
and above details that can be
distracting to uh to abstract algorithms
that that try to con or abstract
examples I mean I try to illustrate a
point without without taking taking the
attention away from the from the main
floor so let's see
um so that was the invitation and um
and then I I must have written back and
uh and asked some questions about
scientific
about about illustrations and then um
and then so he I got a
uh so he so he gives me his idea as to
what uh as to what algorithms mean he
doesn't know what what they mean and so
on but he says that they have 600 000
readers
um and um
and so um uh you should try to uh
address you know you know know your
audience is one of the things so he he's
uh
um telling me this and he says he wants
to get it by October one
um in September on September 29th which
is shortly before October one
he uh he reconsiders and and relents for
for December I remember being yelled
that summer but I must have been
and so on December 15th I did I did get
it to him and uh so he he tells me he's
got the article and so on um it will
take us a little while to give it the
undistracted attention it deserves I'll
I'll read between the lines uh uh we got
to check it out and see if if we're at
all interested
um and uh so then uh January 9th it it
says that uh
um essentially that it's accepted
publication and uh and they are uh
uh but they like to have a balance among
the sciences and so they they delay the
publication and so so this is a form
letter that says uh uh don't call us
we'll call you but we will call you
sometime indeed and um
and they already paid me for it so I so
I cashed in right there and so you know
as far as they're concerned you know
they would probably be glad never to
hear from me again
um okay now let's see
um
February 9th 1977 was when I next heard
that was a year later
um and um
and uh this it's worth quoting from the
beginning of his letter
um
let me emphasize that you may correct or
further rework this copy totally as you
see fit as you know we have undertaken
to make the article slightly easier for
the general reader to get into and to
follow but in the process we may very
well have inadvertently introduced
errors of fact or emphasis we take it
for granted that you will want to repair
such errors but above all let me stress
that we do not prefer our Pros to years
nor are we trying to impose any style of
our own as I've indicated our proposals
have more to do with level of discourse
but if anything strikes you as being
uncharacteristic of your normal mode of
address please do not hesitate to change
it okay well
I I and then in two weeks they would
like to hear and so on so um
um
and so this is a of course a formatter
too but it's well it's uh it so it goes
out to everybody and uh but it gave me
the you know certainly the Liberty to
not to hesitate to change things now I
guess I should I should
resume this stuff I should go before I
get into this part of the story with the
uh with with what went on behind before
that so uh I started out let's see do I
have
do I have my handwritten draft I guess
not
but um
I did
I guess I
as I you know this was Philip Phyllis
typed the first draft here and then I
I made edits it edits to that and I got
a note here on the on her type
manuscript that she saved called so
beautiful I could cry you know I was
telling her that she did
great typing on this thing and now
here's a note to the editors that I
wrote on the on the draft I said I've
tried to imitate Scientific American
style in this dress thus the figures
which appear right there you know I use
a wicked witch
the figure is that up here at the end of
the manuscript are accompanied by
longish captions which that give the
message of the article in capsule form
when the text refers to a figure I've
left a box like so-and-so meaning point
to figure three using a phrase like at
the top of the opposite page which is
what they do
in their style they don't have figure
of course I know that my writing style
is only a curious approximation to yours
so it'll be fun to see what you do to
this my masterpiece all right so that
was what I had sent them
and um
uh okay and then I got back to the
edited Galley uh as we said in February
of uh 77.
um okay now where are we
give you some of the bottom line here
next after I read that so I
I've got three letters that I wrote on
February 17th
um
one of them is to Martin Gardner
uh who as I think you know was a monthly
columnist for the Scientific American
for about 25 years
and retired a few years ago so um he's a
good friend and um so I said dear Martin
on Monday I received the typewritten
manuscript of an article about
algorithms I wrote Scientific American
it was somewhat I was somewhat shocked
by what's he's a very poor editing job
I don't want to cause any hard feelings
by complaining to Dennis Flanagan his
correspondence has always been very
cordial and efficient nor do I want to
waste any of your valuable time but
since I have frequently felt like
screaming at many of the Preposterous
things that were done I must prevent my
feelings somehow by writing them down
I realize that my own style as far from
ideal I intentionally break a lot of
time-honored rules for example starting
sentences with but when I wish to make a
strong point I tie long sentences like
this one together with semicolons when I
really should break them up as newspaper
reporters do but I was astonished to see
how many editorial chains were made that
took perfectly good English and turned
into something that would be worth no
more than B minus on a high school term
paper now here I used that instead of
wish it was pretty good there
example I wrote most common words this
was changed to commonest words the term
not only greats in my eardrums it also
fails to appear in my dictionary
for example I wrote when we study how to
use computers properly problems arise
which excuse me are interesting in their
own right
of course I should have written that and
so the naturally any anybody who reads
this sentence uh and has been trained
that knows that it was written by a poor
writer so it has to be Rewritten here's
what came out in the study of how to
properly employ computers problems that
are interesting in their own right arise
now that was a professional
dude no okay so not only is the
infinitive split you know to properly
employ computers I mean you split
infinitives aren't always wrong but you
don't have to go out of your way to
split them here uh but the whole Rhythm
as a sentence went
uh went away okay example I wrote no
note that we are speaking here about
algorithms whose sole purpose is to
determine the best search tree edited
version I should point out that here I
have been discussing several algorithms
the sole purpose of which is to
determine the best search tree still can
and awkward what now what what do you
think
yeah
it wasn't as bad yeah put push the yeah
yeah push the button when you say
we just we didn't think that was quite
as bad as the other one no the other one
was real it was worse than what you had
originally written okay
uh a comment would help
um yeah
um but the rhythm is just I I thought
this
well it sounded like um engineer Eaves
for sure so uh now here it turned out
that what I didn't know when I submitted
the article that Scientific American
doesn't ever talk about
we in the way that I was accustomed to
doing I hadn't noticed that little
detail of this so so the editor had to
really change it to I here
um
and um
but it's still it's very awkward and
other problems the repetition the same
unusual words in several adjacent
sentences when synonyms could just as
well have been used use of same phrase
to introduce two consecutive sentences
or paragraphs and so on but one more
example should suffice to convey the
great skill of this particular editor
that is a very large number
approximately equal to grunt Pi being
the familiar 3.14159 the most basic law
of mathematical writing is to put words
not just a comma between independent
formulas again the sentence doesn't flow
well so you can see what my original
version was altered into the above
examples I
I want to talk about above later on
sometime
I uh that's controversial if I should
say the examples above or the above
examples we don't ever say the below
examples but we say none of the above
yeah so it would have been better to say
two of the examples above uh but uh I
I'm not you know another another glitch
in my style I didn't know about at the
time I failed to realize scientific
Marine doesn't like to talk about Wing
okay I can adjust to that restriction
well it means a lot of passive voice and
stuffy sentences that one can verify the
resulting prose doesn't have to be so
involuted and contorted as the draft I
received
and I tell about my personal opinion
which you all know know very well it's
hard for me to change the manuscript
back into something I would want my name
to be attached to on the other hand I
suppose that this particular copy that
also thinks that my style is awkward
opaque and Preposterous all I know is I
don't feel like rewriting your cons when
I see them but I felt like changing
about every sentence of this manuscript
something must be different about the
two
so um please don't pause the reply I had
just had to explode a little bit and
explain my feelings that someone out in
my life and my secretary I feel better
now all right uh
uh what oh I stayed in this house a few
times and so on okay yeah yeah we're
um
uh Dear Mr Flanagan here's an edited the
same day of course uh here's an edited
version of the edited version of My
article I followed your advice and
changed because I did not find
characteristic of my normal mode of
address even though this meant a rather
extensive list of changes I have
carefully well here's there I'm
embarrassed to show you this carefully
consider the use of that of this versus
that versus which in other grammatical
things which or that are sometimes in
dispute I also broke the rule about
putting commas and periods inside of
quotation marks in some places since
that rule does not apply when the quoted
thing is a sentence is a sequence of
letters or symbols being referred to in
a technical manner
as that precise sequence then when three
dots appear are they should be raised
and so on and talk about that
um
note that the latter period is outside
the quotes because I'm speaking about a
sequence of symbols one writes okay
referring to when referring to algorithm
a b Etc and steps A1 I've deleted all
italic markings since it's customary and
pure science to use the Roman type in
these contexts
I sincerely hope that I'll have a chance
to read Galley proof since so many
changes were necessary since there are
so much technical material that is
somewhat typographical in nature
um and um I say I'm grateful that you
copied it or found the misprint in one
of my formulas that I would otherwise
have caught and I'm also glad that many
things I glossed over to Hasty are now
stated clearly on the other hand I'm
sorry that I found necessary to disagree
with his or her Pro style in so many
places all I can say is I've tried
diligently to make the finished product
satisfy my ear above all please do not
use the non-word Communist in the
article I thought
well
now then I had another uh another letter
the same day too Flanagan which is about
the uh about the captions and
illustrations which is another another
issue and they I had
um and and the question was how to make
the illustrations work out and they
decided that that would be interesting
to to use to use first names and so they
they made up an example and when I
um
oh wait a minute I guess they used
yeah
uh what is this Zelda it wasn't too hard
to decipher the method by which first
names in figure one were determined once
I noticed Zelda
um because on the on the Masthead of the
of the article
um
it um it mentions of Zelda so I knew
that there was a Zelda on on his staff
and then I conjecture that your
secretary name is Adele and her offices
between years and the Publishers uh uh I
mean there was a list of names in which
uh in which there was Dennis Adele
Gerard apparently and so on so
uh so this was uh some people there at
the staff had had made have made the use
and then I and then I was saying maybe
we should use um
surnames and I talked about the article
in Mad Magazine where where the the
editors there had used had put their
names into my article too well uh but
otherwise Ryan's letter I changed my
decided the best list of surname is
obvious after all Washington Adams
Jefferson Madison and so on and sort of
and so then it made the reasonable
example for the Sorting algorithm and so
okay now so several things were going on
in parallel there and um and I gotta
show you now the article and uh what the
copy of some of the things The copier
did and so on so I got it I gotta get my
tables here ready in parallel
first of all well I guess I'd better
no no I better go through the
correspondence while we're in the
correspondence so here it says March 7th
uh two weeks later and close a proof of
your article together with separate
copies illustrations you may be mildly
interested to know that this is quite
unprecedented in our scheme of things
working as we do with a large
manufacturing printer we must deal with
proofs on a 48-hour cycle this of course
leaves no time for the inter session of
the author normally we do all the
necessary buffing and polishing at an
earlier stage in this case it's good of
nature that material calls for the
closest scrutiny of all concerns
particularly yourself and so on so so
they did something that they that they
never do is sent and they didn't even
have Federal Express Mail in those days
and they when so they're they're working
with Donnelly the biggest printer in the
United States dollar is located in
Chicago and they send him their stuff
from New York
and um
uh
and and Donnelly that the
prints most of the magazines of the of
the country it certainly did at that
time and and still does most of the only
thing
um
and um
so I got these I got these Galley proofs
to to look at so let me line line those
up but then he says now as you will see
in the proof you and we are disagreeing
about two matters of English one is the
proper use of which in that
in this we follow Fowler and since there
is a distinction in the meaning of the
two words we feel it should not be
obliterated by using which
interchangeably with that absolutely
correct and uh and uh the second matter
concerns communist it happens that there
is currently a minor epidemic of putting
perfectly good comparative and
superlative forms aside in favor of
using more and most almost every day I
see more severe or severe just the other
day I saw in the times
most stuffy uh no that one most stuffy I
can see but more but severe I'm not sure
um dictionary gives the comparative and
superlative forms of common as common or
uncommon is so he has a different
dictionary he found a dictionary that
has it it said that J Edgar Hoover used
to pronounce communist as communist
but purely we do not have to worry about
that ambiguity in other words we would
prefer to stick with the traditional
usage and so we have gone and then we've
gone along with you and and um about the
quotes and things like that we greatly
appreciate aha the pains he took in
going through the edited copying and so
on and anyway says that well it's his
words are
are somewhat true there
okay so I
um
and I have to say um and I show you the
letter that Martin wrote to me too
um I'm glad you wrote to me about those
difficulties and I'd like to reply when
I suggested I need problem has come up
before with articles by top
mathematicians I find it hard to
understand why I work entirely at home
have little contact with the other
physics at once a month when I usually
go in for lunch and the entire editorial
staff has the Harvard Club I know that I
knew that your piece had been accepted
that Dennis liked it very much but I
have no notion at the moment of who is
assigned to it I'll try to find out
discreetly at the next lunch I I know
that that oolonged ulam who died a
couple years ago but he was extremely
unhappy about the editing of the last
article he wrote for essay and once you
quote I would certainly agree with your
feelings and I wish you would write
Dennis a letter I considered passing on
to him but after thinking about I prefer
not because he didn't want to have
strain relations I should you know he
says needless to say I wouldn't want to
see a copy of this letter let's hide
this whole thing here but he's but he's
a you know he goes on and it's rather
rather
um and then he goes on tells me some
mathematical news and so on and I wrote
him a note saying I decided to forget
about my unhappiness with the writing
style of that particular essay editor
um I decided that the editors have so
much to do in so little time there's no
chance for them really to polish things
up mathematics computer science article
but sufficiently unusual is to
constitute a real headache anyway
I spent one and a half thousand hours
working with this particular editor by
phone on the revisions to the galley
proof so I'm pleased with the way
everything has turned out if I hadn't
been so tired when the original
manuscript came in it arrived on top of
three other crises I would never have
been upset anyway I would just have
written the incident off like I have on
a half dozen other times I've confronted
the media it takes a rare Talent like
Gina Berry coladas uh to to do this kind
of writing that she's one of the best
writers about mathematics so I shouldn't
be upset when everybody doesn't have it
so that's the sort of the conclusion of
the correspondence part of this I don't
have to go back to that
uh
let's see so I got the article that I
and I got the copy editing and then I
got the page proof and I can show you
the final article because somehow we
have to we have to look through this
thing the way in order to understand
this you have to have to collate a whole
bunch of different stuff
I hope a bunch of different stuff that
goes into this uh writing okay so I've
got the um
yeah
here is what I where here's what I wrote
and sent them
um and then
the last thing I have to
okay
um
okay came out here actually it has
also another illustration that was
wasn't in my in my original manuscript
here I got a
advertisements are also sprinkled or of
course magazines are supposed to uh
aren't supposed to sell things and so
they
so they
so I imagine they didn't have had one of
their rare computer ads in those days
but uh so it did come out
um and uh so I could so in case you have
to look at what actually came out in the
in the real
world
uh I have to go to that okay so now
what's next here all right
um
uh the beginning of the article
was completely Rewritten and I should
say it at the
at and at the beginning as I said it's
the most important part uh and that's
where you want to get the reader hooked
and here oh it's the great I had um was
a great advantage of course at the copy
editor doesn't know computer science and
so you can see exactly where I'm using
jargon where I'm in where that's where
I'm blind to these things and um so my
original my my start my first first
paragraph Was Not was not at all great
ten years ago it would not have been
unusual for a scientist to think that
the word algorithm was simply a careless
typist rendition of the word logarithm
rapid rise of computer science which has
the study of algorithms that his main
focal point has now changed the
situation algorithm increasingly appears
in people's vocabularies
I mean right now I even overhear people
using it uh
uh in buses you know but this wasn't
true in 1977. perhaps in another 10
years newspaper reporters will even be
able to assume that their readers know
what an algorithm is
I think that happened in 10 years yeah
well so anyway I our language has
several words that almost describe the
concept procedure recipe process routine
and so on this was mine yeah so now
let's see what happened what came out
okay so 10 years ago the word algorithm
was unknown to most educated people
indeed it was scarcely necessary first
of all
no
she doesn't want to say scientists
because the Scientific American goes to
educated people of course and so on the
rapid rise of computer science has
changed all that the word is NOW
essential there are several other words
that almost but not quite capture the
cons this is her her correction capture
the concept of an algorithm procedure
and so on method she left out the word
rigmarole which I thought was uh was
reasonable but you know and an algorithm
is a set of rules now notice that these
sentences are all uh short
and uh that was better than mine where
my sentences tended to be to be quite
rather long and so on and so she so it
got in there but um
uh but I still wanted I had to put I
wanted to put in the uh
um a plug for uh uh algorithms as being
a main part of computer science that's
perhaps say one of the more important
unifying principles because I did I want
I wanted people to realize this
um and uh so anyway but anyway so
um and in general there are many of
things in in my article that got greatly
improved by means of this of this of
this rewrite uh especially taking out
the jargon and then uh and then slowing
things down where I was going too fast
at a bad Pace
um so so the fact is then that I could
having the rewrite was it was a great
Advantage for the final quality of the
of the of the of the product on the
other hand a rewrite of the rewrite
which is what I said to my lawyer Dennis
was was much much better was was you
know sort of uh tourism attitude better
than the originals
and uh and again I was able to get rid
of all the all the all the glitches um
that that came out now let's see so but
let's let's go into
um
I don't understand why the copy there
would change it changed uh I had written
can fruitfully be studied and she
changes to can be fruitfully studied
um I have no idea so I could put it back
again
um
okay now let's see
well I should get more into uh into
things that are that are General than
than two specific and so um here was one
of the here was one of the cases where
where the jargon had to be
had to be changed and what and so we can
take a look at this now so this is the
you can by the way typographically you
can tell that that you can tell when I'm
showing you something that came out of
Scientific American it was in this it
was written with you know with this
funny word processor this 1977 uh uh
that um that uh it tries to estimate the
uh the way the breaks are going to the
amount of copy that you have so that
they can figure out how many column
inches they have for the magazine
um
let's see
um so I have said during this I said
during this algorithm Jay will take the
values n n minus one dot dot dot until
either reaching zero or a location
containing the input word X and if you
change it um saying in the execution of
the algorithm J Will sequentially take
the values n n minus one n minus two and
so on until reaching either zero or our
locations and so this dot dot dot was
you know the was not good here we wanted
to have this and so on
um and um
I uh and so I didn't like the way the
way that came out but I uh but I did but
it wasn't too hard to
subsequent steps will will cause Jay to
run through the sequence of values n n
minus one and so on then if then it made
sense to me I put a comma here I don't
know if that one survived but that's not
too important
um
previous page
I had um
I had said
oh this is about the I versus we
although numerical methods have many
features of Interest we shall concern
ourselves in this article with examples
of non-numerical algorithms in order to
emphasize the fact that algorithm scale
primarily with the manipulation of
symbols that need not represent numbers
now
um
I wasn't using we I mean
Oh it sounded like I was using we in a
formal sense because I'm talking about
in this article uh somehow
if we're really using we as you and me
we would say in this discussion or
something like this but the word article
is sort of is sort of uh it wasn't
wasn't the perfect use of we in my in my
my uh ideal sense and and naturally uh
so uh this whole article was Rewritten
in in first person with I and so it said
so um her see although numerical
algorithms have many interesting
features I shall confine this discussion
to non-numerical algorithms in order to
emphasize the fact that algorithms deal
primarily with the symbols and so on now
um
I guess
it's a
so I so I switched over to I it's okay
on the final one but I but I
I I crossed out present here too I
couldn't this discussion I wanted to say
the following discussion to
non-numerical ones I didn't want to say
algorithms algorithms by the time it was
uh it was too too many times in a row I
guess
but the main thing here is that I that
that she changed it to something where I
where it's taught where it's me talking
and and I and that was okay uh but I
didn't want to emphasize myself all the
way through so so a lot of the other
stuff had to be changed into passive
voice
let's see where are we here
um
okay algorithm a sequential search we
already talked about here's something
what is this what do I have this flagged
here you see that
um they had a great big space between K
and the
and the uh uh the subscript there in no
space around the equal sign and
and this is typical when you try to put
mathematics into a typesetting system
that isn't accustomed to it
and
um
the term KJ means that the word is
stored at location J and and that and I
had to change that around but I'm not
sure exactly why I flagged this one
um
that's not that
that important I guess
um
I I let's see here
I was talking about a trick of putting
something giving some meaning to key
zero so it's so so here I had to rewrite
quite a bit
um
you know because she had asked the
question and so in order to explain the
question it's better to have a better to
say in words what more what was going on
um okay so anyway uh but the main thing
here is that I I had written in my
original manuscript I just said
unfortunately
and then I didn't say
anything else I just said unfortunately
um where is my
where's my manuscript here I said
unfortunately the most commonly used
computer programming language is
standard 420 and Cobalt don't allow zero
as an index so this Improvement couldn't
be made easily in such languages so now
what actually came out she started out
first and says unfortunately for
programmers the most commonly used ah
the commonest
communistly used I don't know the most
commonly used computer
um uh a language can programming
languages
um uh do not allow zero and so
um yeah that was that was so reasonable
when you start with something
unfortunately it seems very clear to you
that it's unfortunate but it doesn't
seem clear to the rest of the world you
know to who to to what subclass of
people it's unfortunate so although it's
still a little bit awkward it was
necessary to say that I now realize
um
okay so
okay so that happened there let's see
now
now here was one that got really
clobbered
um
okay
then we're as large as a million this
would be a very big way to search the
table I'm talking about sequential
search we must be searching such a large
table frequently otherwise we wouldn't
have gone to the expense of building it
so we had better not waste time during
the search
according to change if n where is
largest there's a million a simple
sequential search would be a very poor
way to look through the table and if we
needed to write an algorithm to search
through such a large table we would have
to have some reason to be searching the
table frequently otherwise we would not
have gone to the expense of compiling it
therefore it is best not and so on so on
well okay now
um
uh I I put we back in there somehow
let's see what what actually came out of
the
um what I what actually came out that's
um yeah but we got to survive anyway
yeah
okay so in the uh in the article but it
does the sense that actually the
paragraph actually came out to be
reasonably well in a simple sequential
sense would usually be unbearably slow
way to go through we would hardly go to
the expensive building such a large
table unless we expected to search it
frequently and we would not want to
waste any time during the search so in
something like that
it's we can do better than that that
um uh the word we was allowed to survive
in that
in that case here
1642 East 56th Street I have I'm feeding
that scientific Americans offices I
don't know
um is that I don't know
well
um
uh a lot of the things I did were just
simple like here she's here it says
search in the next sentence says
searching again just change it to
another word looking it looked and
sounds reads a little reads more
interesting way
um
let's see now
and when looking up someone when one is
looking up someone's name I I'm just
having to
to uh to make this is just going back to
the present tense instead of oh active
voice instead of passive voice
um
what must be done in the event of an
unsuccess
uh okay
I think I better skip to something
that's more
my life here so now here's another case
where where uh where something I wrote
had to be quite expanded
um I said
this out this algorithm uses and assumes
also that key one less than or equal key
two less than or equal three dots less
than or equal key n so here this got
Rewritten into a long explanation
moreover it is assumed that the word
started location one key one is less
than or equal to this the word started
location two key two
she had capital L there it didn't sound
right Which is less than or equal to the
word sort of location three key three
and so on all the way up to the word
stored in location and keyn and so uh
this condition can be written and then
she gives the uh the formula here
throwing in an extra key three that
wasn't present
um now when um let's look at the at the
at the page groups
um
that came in
it's unfortunately just because she had
this extra one that didn't fit in a line
but but there's a very strange break and
um and uh so we had to uh now I was now
at this point it was too late to make
any changes that would affect the number
of lines in the in the article so it had
to be had to be transposed
downward
um
uh but uh what did they actually they
actually got it to look
to look reasonable somehow except that
they changed it to less than size
instead of less than or equal signs
whoops I didn't catch that
oops oh well there it is wow
I found out that
wow my goodness 600 oh gosh that's
terrible now
um
the when I found out when I talked to
her on the telephone is is that the
editors in New York City have to write
the captions for these and and figure
them out so that so that the last line
of every caption is flush right
and that and they actually calculate
they count letters and and and the
length of of letters and they can't in
New York and then phone this to Chicago
and and then um you know and take what
they you know and uh like like here was
a case where where the um they had
problem in the in this in this line here
but each line break is is hand
determined uh at this time this was 1977
and and these people have a two-day
deadline I mean they're spending all
their time doing doing crazy stuff like
that no wonder she couldn't polish my
heart
and so anyway I could solve this one by
just taking out some some words of that
line but um uh but every every single uh
caption was uh was was made to fit like
this and then they had this neat
algorithm for for doing it and that is
that they they removed the word the
um starting at the end of the caption
and and going back to the beginning as
as much as far as they needed you look
at the
um like
um
uh which is left boundary of search
meaning that Gibbs is not in table you
see what I mean if uh yeah if we go to
the end of captions and Scientific
American the the word the
intends to disappear with the amount of
increase in frequency I think this is
wonderful
okay
um
now let's see um
okay here's a here's an example of
something that they've got that that is
typical also of refereeing and they they
wanted more information so I had written
in original I had said in fact why Pearl
and it's high of of an inch she says
what institution have recently shown
that something or other and and then I
meanwhile a better theorem had been
proved by Andy and Francis Francisco
They Came to Stanford and uh this and so
I you know I changed that and I could
put the the institutions in here but
this um but this was one of the
one of the things that they that they uh
um uh encouraged me to uh to supply
information as to as to the place where
there's where these people uh live here
now here's an I just want to show you
this that uh although although in the
first paragraph she she changed my
senses to nice and short ones here's one
that says on the other hand for search
is executed by computer experience she
never likes comments
is actually by computer experience has
shown that an interpolation search is
usually not an improvement over a binary
search both because accessibility is the
memory of a computer is typically not
random enough and because the extra
calculation per comparison required by
the interpolation takes more time than
the amount of time that is saved by
reducing the number of comparisons now
my original sentence was was uh I think
that was originally two two or three
sentences of mine and so uh so I you
know broke them broke them back up again
into something else
uh another
um uh
split infinitive
here's where the punctuation was was uh
was relevant for the 20
20 the 31 communist English words here
talking about the words a and and so on
uh this is my comma here
um
but she puts the eight she puts the
comma inside the quotes uh which is you
know the rule that you would find in the
in the grammar in the English books but
not when you're referring to it as as a
word that's going to be stored in the
table so if we all know that
that's where that came from here's a
sentence that said in that way the
address of the word the would be now if
this had been in a caption
um
um a lot of times uh it was like you
said thus the Collision is avoided this
was technically incorrect that's the
search will be carried out properly even
when collisions occur it's the correct
way to say it so so uh but but it was
clear to me that when when uh when she
made that error that other people would
you know so I needed to uh
as as again whenever a referee gives you
a comment that's wrong it's still this
it still means that there was a defect
in the original
some sort
okay
um
here she asked me like a referee would
do
um yeah I know we're running out of time
um
but we had this long formula then she
says which is approximately equal to
what simple equation and so she asked me
to supply some mathematics here so it
was a it was a uh a job that was well
done in the sense of also asking asking
for further information that you
expected the author could Supply even
and uh and I'll continue the story on
Friday